are your kids adults yeah my son is 17
and my daughter is 19. let's talk about
their
future
we have the story from the washington
examiner arizona attorney general seeks
invasion status to tackle illegal
immigration
i saw a video of thousands of people
marching through uh central america and
south america and mexico carrying the
flags of their own countries
as they try they announced they were
coming to the united states and then
when the conservatives were saying it
was an invasion the media on the left
said that it was hate speech that it was
a talking point and i'm just sitting
here like
i i don't know man i saw a video of like
a thousand people carrying the flags of
their own country trying to come to ours
and then i watched them attack border
guards
so i kind of feel like
look you you might not like the idea of
the word but it qualifies
it's truly an invasion anybody who says
it isn't either is uneducated
or lying
i've been down on the border there are
people coming over all day every day and
sometimes in small groups of nine and
ten sometimes 250 rush the border
we see the video there
well at least now we know if they've got
the flag which country to send them back
to because we can't absorb them here in
we're not going to absorb them in
arizona so uh mark brnovich as i
pronounce it is calling on governor doug
ducey to uh invoke invasion status and
take action
two questions i suppose do you think
it'll happen and if you were governor
would you do it yeah we should have done
it a long time ago in the beginning of
january i put together my border policy
and the first thing you do is you issue
a declaration of invasion
and invoke basically your article 1
section 10
rights as a state to protect your people
when you're in danger and you have an
invasion you have to declare the
invasion to kind of get that ball
rolling i gave my plan to governor ducey
and i said please take this you can have
it you can rename it you can call it the
ducey plan whatever but do it you can't
wait until i'm governor january 23 we
can't go another year
with thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people pouring across the
cartels being in control the drugs
pouring across killing and weakening
americans
we can't do it and he's done nothing
he's done nothing he's done nothing no
and then he you know
he'll do a dog and pony show at the
border and it's like
do you not see what's happening here do
you not care about arizona i don't know
if it's because he's a lame duck and
it's gonna take too much work but we're
going to on day one i'll take my hand
off the bible after the oath of office
and we're going to issue a declaration
of invasion we're going to put the
arizona national guard at the border and
we're going to arm them and we're going
to stop people from coming across
unfortunately the border patrol can't do
that
they're under joe biden right they're
federal and they're forced to just
process these people and they come over
with smiles on their face they're like
wow land of the free here we are
and it's destroying the middle class um
these what's really sad if you really
can care about people
if you really care about people and are
compassionate these people coming over
millions of them are basically
indentured servants to the cartels
you come over and you owe the cartel for
your passage into america and it's
thousands of dollars you've got to work
to pay off
sometimes they never can because much
like student loan debts for instance
they say you're going to owe us more
there's going to be interest you'll
never be able to pay it off this was a
wristband given to me by jorge ventura
from it was on one of the i guess you
call them migrants one of the uh
this is entrecas which means delivered
they were being delivered by cartel they
were they they were labeled 4186 is the
number but that was for that was for
children
this
shoes everywhere i just got chills
actually thinking about the last time i
was there children's clothes children's
shoes
children coming across something is
deeply wrong with this country when you
have a political faction of millions of
voters who would
protect these people the cartels protect
the coyotes you remember when donald
trump was debating and he said the
coyotes are bringing people across and
these blue checkmark journalists did not
know what a coyote was and they all
laughed and thought trump was talking
about animals because they weren't smart
enough to google search to know what
that means yeah you have young girls
being abused by human traffickers
and it's because joe biden will not
deal with this and you know you know
what biden did instead of securing the
border
he started putting these miners on
planes and flying them across the
country to sweep it under the rug oh you
see it every every time we fly out we
flew here and you see people in the
airport they don't have id they just
have their basically their court
paperwork to show up at court that's we
have to show our id you know hand over
everything and they're they're all over
the airport
and they're being shipped to a city near
you and this is why
people from all 50 states have gotten
involved in our campaign because they
know
we are going to protect the border in
arizona and this is a national issue not
an arizona issue it's a national issue
and if we don't get strong governors in
our border states we're gone we're done
as a country if there's an invasion
status declared and they get armed can
they just mow down civilians no and
that's not what we're doing i mean this
is kind of what the liberals will say
what do you want to we want our our
arizona national guard and our guard
members and we're going to ask other
states to send their guard down as well
we need boots on the ground to protect
our our border
this is to protect our our national
guard we're dealing with the cartels
you know you don't have to watch that
many issues of any any movie dealing
with a cartel breaking bad they're not
friendly people okay we're not going to
have our guard members be killed while
they're down there protecting us
and we're just going to stop people when
we catch them we're going to process
them and we're sending them back and we
have a couple of brave
uh sheriffs in texas you've been
following that they finally are saying
hey we want to declare an invasion if
our governor won't do it we will do it
and one of them had processed some
people they were involved in an accident
or something and they refused service
they refused going to the hospital and
so he took him he drove him right back
to the port of entry dropped him off and
said wow adios so we have this story
from tim cass tech center gov texas
governor abbott authorizes national
guard dps to arrest illegal migrants and
return them to the border i don't think
he he he didn't declare invasion but
he's getting you know he's kind of on
the edge sending the national guard out
to deal with this
what do you what do you think of what
he's doing do you think he's doing a
well enough job he's getting pressured
the people are going come on what how
much worse does this have to get
before we see these governors grow a
spine i mean
why aren't they doing it how hard is it
i i think our government's
uh part and parcel to this i mean i
think the federal government last time i
was there i watched three van loads of
illegals being brought in
and the border agent stopped with the
third van he rolled the window down he
said i'm voting for you but you've got
to stop this this is the 2873rd
illegal alien i've processed and this
was early in may this was like the first
week
2873rd illegal alien i've processed at
this spot that's one guy
and he said it's got to stop and he's
right i don't know why our governors
aren't doing anything um other than
they're weak or maybe they're open
borders types maybe they want to see
this big global agenda i don't know but
i do know this it's going to stop and
it's going to stop in january of 2023
and
we are going to win this election oh
yeah that's why they're that's why
they're writing hit pieces every week
that's why they're attacking me that's
why they're going so hard i think i'm
their least favorite person other than
donald trump right now because they know
i'm not in politics because i want a
career in politics i'm in politics
because i'm a fed up mom who's sick of
seeing our state being trampled
and is sick of seeing the crime and the
drugs come in i want to get in there
stop this insanity and get back to my
life what do you think about ron
desantis love him we need more governors
like him as well and if we're gonna get
one right from the sound of it it's
fascinating how the never trumper types
uh chris ruffo you're familiar with
christopher ruffo
no who is that he's uh how would you
describe him one of the leading
academics on critical race theory and
gender ideology critical race theory
stuff in the pacific northwest for like
years now he's great he said that
desantis is basically the litmus test
for never trumpers because they should
support him he's uh got military
experience he's a a he's well-spoken
he's not you know crass he's
conservative he's wonderful and they
don't he's effective right but so why is
it that these
never trumper conservatives don't
support desantis they have no good
reason like trump and desantis and even
christy gnome to to an extent and and
like i'm going to be we are going to be
effective and we're going to show how
worthless
this last generation of politicians have
been
trump exposed all of that he made
everyone look like a big fool
they made us believe that it took 20
years to get one little thing done a
bridge built the money for a bridge to
be built i mean we had a town in arizona
that a big community where
um every time it rained
the road would flood and you couldn't
pass it you couldn't pass over going
from one side of town to the other and
so you had to take a 40-mile detour they
were begging begging begging for federal
dollars to build a bridge so that this
town basically could function when it
rained
it took him 20 years
it took i think dozens of people had to
die in that flooded road and that's what
we were we were taught that that's how
long it takes the federal government
it's like a cold day molasses flowing on
a cold day you can't get anything done
trump goes in and boom
right away he says all these promises
and everyone said he'll never do it boom
he starts going down his to-do list and
gets everything done while he's being
simultaneously attacked by the swamp
attacked by the media and we realized oh
my gosh
he's the he's the effective one these
other people are just lifers who are
you know don't care about us it'd be
cool if when you're governor if you have
like a local state thing where people in
their localities can vote even like on
an app or something to redirect a
portion of their tax funds their state
tax funds to like local issues and then
if they can get enough people to to
swipe right on their issue and allocate
like one percent so like a tinder for
tax money
this is actually uh is that what tinder
is exactly swipe left
i love this idea
the general idea is obviously you can't
do it with all taxes but there could be
like a certain percentage where it's
like let's see how the people feel about
these issues
and you could be like download the app
take the survey and the vote on what
issue you think and then we'll show
everybody how everyone on the app voted
and then
is it
swipe right or left is yes swipe right
okay swipe right is good yes of course
the right but the the bottom thing is
difficult right is correct bots that's
difficult yeah you'd have to like sign
up with your social security number you
know be like a you'd be a citizen you'd
have local whatever that's great
we could do that wouldn't it be nice if
we did that with federal money i wonder
how many people would have swiped right
for the 58 billion going to ukraine yeah
and in those situations i imagine we
would still have like black budget 30
you're not allowed to spend less than
that like like you just have to accept
fire department police department it's
going to be great out at seven percent
but there could be stuff like new skate
but you could put more tennis i
guarantee you the wall would have been
built a long time ago yeah and i'll
guarantee you ukraine would not be
taking our tax money it works with like
popular support i mean we are a popular
support
government it's you vote to get the
people in if you could vote for the
things you want as well that's the
appearance
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you